hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
inscription
with this guy
who guy this guy i see you right there
what
oh
knife i'm gonna kill you
you finally pried my special dagger from
the paws of that squirrel though you may
wish that you hadn't
why may i wish that i had not
why may i had not wish that i did that
clock
[Music]
oh knife
that one's only for card dueling
i don't know what that means anyway back
to the card game which is the real
important thing here is there another
like thing here
more secrets you know
probably sure can
yeah what's all with this what's with
all this what's with all this nonsense
this black goop
this better not be what i think it is
it's time to throw down in the wetlands
and by throw down i mean get a card
and i hope it's
the tragic rat king when their tangled
bodies became corpses you will gain four
bones
well that's nice river snapper god i
wish i had made that two cost that would
have been a great one
now it's not so good
but whatever it's fine i think i'll go
with the new one just to like explore
all the mechanics before i incredibly
die again
what does this mean i get to destroy a
card from my deck i might as well
combine i got a lot of cards in my deck
i think i need to combine them all right
now i'm gonna remember this is getting
sacrificed this is what's getting
sacrificed and then it's fine wait a
minute
wait a minute
are you seeing what i'm seeing are you
seeing what possibly i am seeing i put
this with the cockroach oh yeah
and then
every time the cockroach dies it goes
back to my hand but i get four bones is
that an infinite four bone loop i think
yes
i think yes all i need to do is get the
four bones to play it in the first place
and then i'm golden
i'm a genius
oh
oh i don't like that what does that do
i don't know what that do what are you
doing
kingfisher i don't know what that means
when an opposing creature is placed
opposite to an empty space a card
sparing the sigil will move to that
empty space okay oh i see it just always
goes to the face where things are and i
see i see i see okay well i can't play
anything so i guess i'll do nothing
ow well this is going to go poorly for
me boy this is not ideal look
there's a third talking card somewhere
around here personally
i hate that guy
biggest killjoy ever
but he's the only one of us with a plan
to get things
back to normal
okay whatever you say man i'm gonna do
one of these
and then one uh
oh you incus
you're gonna move to a spot where it is
no matter what right but i can't kill
you
so whatever it don't matter
bad play you're a bad play shut up i
only got one bone but technically i
could get a bone from the rabbit but
it's not really a good idea
all right whatever let's do it take that
ow
that's not good okay
let's see what we get
a skunk okay watch this nonsense
skink get the bones for my opinion
opossum
boom
now it's going back in my favor
except it's probably wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah
these damn things going underground it's
not doing me a lot of good if i could
just get this cockroach
worker ant that sounds good i like the
sound of that i can't play the sound of
that but i like the sound of that
okay
okay this is gonna go south real quick
if i don't do something okay i know what
i'm gonna do
play the squirrel
play the ant
[Music]
yeah this will be fine it'll be fine
because now i'm doing four damage
and he's gonna do four damage and that's
fine
oh he hit my guys but that's fine
because the ant's still there and that's
all that matters
what does this do the car bearing the
suit will be struck a tail has created
his place in the card-bearing decision
moves to the right
interesting
either way what am i gonna do you
concede no
hold on oh you shut up i'm gonna kick
your ass i'm gonna kick your ass from
here to tuesday you shut your mouth i'm
having a great time
eat my ass [ __ ]
because i'm about to kill you so good a
boom and boom and i put you there
i get an ant
i play an ant
kill the stoat put this here do about
eat that ass you conceding [ __ ]
that's right
that's right that's right you should
feel bad about that you should feel bad
about that you should feel embarrassed
about that you've encountered a small
outpost in the woods tended by a
mysterious woman
it was the traitor that the old trapper
had mentioned
her appearance was unsettling but you
were mollified by her
offerings hi lady
do you mind if i examine those pelts of
yours
sure
let's start with your hair pelts
here's what i can offer i can trade you
any of these
take your time
uh
oh
what sacrificial goat hell yeah beaver
it's a beaver dew damn builder when
they're bearing the signal the dam is
created on each adjacent space oh
well that's defensive not what i'm
looking for though love the idea of a
sacrificial goat
that's kind of fun what is that one
hefty carburetor in the soul will move
in the direction described by the sigil
of creatures in the way we'll be pushing
oh interesting well that's not what i'm
here i love the blood give me the give
me that
oh wolf pelts too
exquisite
oh look at the cat the cat
hell yeah give me the cat
the cat these pelts are most excellent
my thanks
okay thanks lady
all right i have a good one oh let's
super boost something i don't know what
we can but i've got too many cards so i
need to pair them down a little bit all
right what do we got what if i put the
sacrificial goat what if i sacrifice a
sacrificial goat so that something else
can get sacrificed let's see what i
could put
this into
i could put the three blood on
with sacrificial opossum i can make a
sacrificial opossum if i play blood to
get them then i always have kind of a
blood bag there but it costs bones to
play blood that doesn't make any sense
maybe just leave the sacrificial guy as
the sacrificial guy and that'll be it
let's let's not let's change this i
could just make the mole man super fun
he also has a tail let's just super buff
the mole man because this is what i feel
like
bam now the mole man every time he
struck creates a tail
that's pretty dope
okay i could get another sigil fight or
i could just get a normal fight let's go
for the normie
i got a good feeling about this one i
got a great feeling about this hey
there's my goat
oh my god wait what the hell
wait a minute
i think i just won
hang on a second
i play this
to play the goat and i play this
do i not have leftover
blood ah no i don't have leftover blood
damn it well i'm still off to a great
start what do you got over there great
oh that's not good
well that's a problem actually it's not
a problem because i like i said i'm
about to win
wouldn't you know it bam
well that made it pretty easy for me
boy those ants are kind of powerful all
right well time for the trap man again
i've got the most exquisite pants
i don't know it's a terrible accent
terrible aye that's right that hurston's
free
all right thank you for the first and
much appreciate wait whoa whoa
i forgot how that went why you be such a
douche bag to me god damn it ah let's
combine them why not let's see what
happens i like the sacrificing thing
that's pretty fun all right so the black
goat is kind of not as good as i thought
because i don't have many things that
cost three but it is nice to have but i
could always apply that to something
else just the same because it still
costs one i can make a rabbit pelt
sacrificial then it would be free can i
do that
but i'll lose it don't be stupid don't
be stupid me all right let's just make
the bull frog this because uh
well
god is my only mm-hmm
[Music]
let's just make the bullfrog
yay
all right i feel good about that that's
fine that's fine and if i don't need him
right now right away he doesn't have a
non-use
oh hell yeah oh i forgot my stinky
warren i forgot about that one okay what
are you gonna do coyote that's a lot of
cards right off the bat there pal that's
a lot of cards what does this do
you will place a weight on the scale the
pain is temporary
oh
the thing about the warren is it's not
going to really last long but at least
it would be kind of a defense
interesting all right whatever let's
let's see what happens
okay that's gonna be there and that's
gonna put a rabbit in my hand then what
i could do after that is get another
card get the ant queen out put another
ant down that warrant's not gonna make
it but whatever or i could play my bones
get bones put the cockroach down right
away i guess i should have put it ah you
know what i need bones
i'm just gonna go ahead and play bones
because why not
okay that sounds good
hi
hi your stink is stupid what a stupid
stink what a stupid stink all right uh
play the ant queen mo stef
i could yeah i could oh i got it i got
it i got it i got it
i got it okay this did make it
sacrifice those two but this here
that'll kill that
put this here
sacrifice that for one of these
bamboom were in business yeah
nice
nice try dill weed ow
well you should have blocked up that
route it's not good for you now oh an
opossum finish her off boys
oh [ __ ] i thought i was done
ow
well that's not enough dickholes
mole man all right whatever let's do
this i'm gonna win boom boom
that's how you do it all right have i
got anything else to
solve this mystery around here
it probably is right there probably
definitely is this clock is a mystery
this is a mystery it's not really
anything i can do for that though
this has been all solved
yeah that's already been solved that's
not different this has been solved i got
that dagger
that's nice oh hi
all right i got nothing but let's do it
i actually enjoy this game so i'm gonna
keep playing another card
excellent the vervet mantis it's bryan
claws frank both left and right
the coyote
the wonderful frog leaps in the way of
attacking flyers
well i already have one i know oh my
guess i could use another bone thing
considering i got this little cockroach
bone strategy going on
although i could sacrifice another one
again but i don't really want to because
i'm
i need a backpack
oh
if you demon necessary you may cut up
one of my cards with these oh i'm gonna
go for the bones
a guess from this may lift your
creatures into the air if for only a
turn uh i mean kind of cool i like the i
like the look of the fan i'll get it
just because i like the bird legs
whatever it's kind of fun all right boss
time i'm gonna kick some ass here i'm
gonna kick some ass
and whatever seems unfair
a foul smell invaded your nostrils and
caused your throat to seize
a hulking man sat by a brackish pond
with his feet submerged in the dark
water
he pulled a hook from a pile of rotting
fish and rose to his feet
i am the angler
go fish
okay well kind of goopy in here
wow that's a lot of cards you gave me
what is it going on here kingfisher i
don't that's what you've been testing me
for
the goddamn fish all right now let's see
what we got here i don't got anything
that could possibly help me in terms of
actually being useful
so thanks for that i should have gotten
more bullfrogs those would have been
very useful it's kind of like my flying
defense i forget if i could sacrifice
this can i sacrifice this
oh i can oh
interesting i could get the wolf on the
board right away that'd probably be
useful
all right let's do that
shall we bam
well that made it easy he shall go
unopposed eat my ass
wow
which fish
hard to choose
i don't think that was the original
voice what oh oh wait wait whoa whoa
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing there what are you doing hold
on now
no let's not be so hasty
damn it oh yay not damn it
let's see what happens fresher fish
easy choice
oh cool
that's kind of fun is that fun
seems like fun
i'm going to say it's fun bam
[Laughter]
so stupid
you're so stupid go fish
[Music]
oh
babe bucket
i don't like the sound of that
ah my warren excellent
i don't i don't know what that's about i
don't like what that's about is that
gonna put like you know chum the waters
and then thus there will might be a like
shark or something i don't i don't like
the sound of whatever that is i guess i
could kill the opossum get the warrant
out and then have something in my card
for
or my hand for the next one and then
possibly don't have to deal with two of
those if that does
end up being something that kills
something so
yeah let's see what happens i don't know
got a rabbit in here
i could always put the worker ant out or
i could save and see what happens next
time
i knew it i knew it i
knew it
i knew it ow oh my god that thing does
four i knew it was bad i knew it was bad
oh how did i know it would be bad
it's me i know it's you uh
so um uh i'm gonna need you to take one
for the team here because that hurt
that's gonna hurt all right you give a
rabbit so i got this dude
i guess i should have put you there
because then no one would have oh you're
an attack spot oh god
okay well this is clear that i gotta put
you there and then i guess i gotta put
the uh
worker ant
there at least and that's something damn
i ain't got much else stupid rabbit pelt
okay that's helpful
oh goodbye buddy
bullfrog oh none of these things fly and
you're sacrificial but what good did
that do me it does mean none good
oh man
oh man oh man okay you know what this is
gonna hurt it's gonna hurt
oh
good god
okay so i'm in trouble i don't have
anything that could possibly defend
against this okay wolf is good because
at least it could attack this round so
what i can do is i can get out the
bullfrog
to get rid of that
put the bullfrog down put this kill that
put that there if only i had things that
could play bones i guess i could put
that in the way if i need to it is
something i guess i didn't need to get
hit i forgot that that's the thing that
i could have just ah i could have just
done that
well that's dumb all right whatever i'm
dumb but let's just see what happens
god my wolf should be here but whatever
it's fine
oh
god this is so unhelpful i have so much
resource and not enough anything
what do i need oh wow oh my my face
oh
oh god
is that gonna be the whole game now
let me re-light your candles
oh god i'm blind
i could have won that without the i
thought i thought that i i thought oh
you may choose a rare card
okay thank you
oh my eyeball mole man
long help
i now i need a big card because i just
don't have nearly enough to do anything
so i'm gonna get the my mole man is not
popped up at all i'm gonna get the ooh
believe it or not you're not the first
to lose an eye here
this isn't much fun if you're half blind
perhaps you'd like to replace it i would
actually
oh wow uh oh my goodness
these are fun this is a fun one
thank you
i see so good out of that eye now
better
regardless the choice is final
okay thank you
you considered one of the anglers
catches as a meal the rank holder
deterred you
dinner
would have to wait
i love this game i really do this game
is super fun let me
see
huh
a frigid gust of wind billowed unwelcome
into your lungs
the beauty of the falling snow failed to
distract you from the chill in your
bones
he had ascended to the snow line
okay cool i see the trapper up there i
just wish i would have been able to get
more
more pelts it's not my fault all right
let's do this i'm gonna go this way for
the trapper because i do have a pelt
anyway so i might as well i guess
hi
the invaluable beehive when it is
attacked you won't draw a bee cool
the regal noose
oh what the what the what the
apothecized goat the truest offering
sacrificing it grants three blood i
don't like this goat and how it's
looking at me i i don't like that i
don't like that nun i don't like the way
that ghost looking at me i feel
uncomfortable maybe i should get the
moose because i don't have nearly enough
big
big buck items then the
you know the way that ghost looking at
me
no i could not never i could
something about that go
no i must
i'm going for the goat i just i can't i
know it's not a logical choice
i'm gonna sacrifice this ghost so it
doesn't look at me anymore maybe i could
make it more powerful
yeah maybe but just put this goat down
[Music]
what if i put that goat on another black
goat and then it was like a six oh man
that would be that would be really
something huh that would be really
something anyway
is it hot in here or what i guess man
you know i can't why sacrifice it once
here when i can sacrifice it
oh man all right and queen you gotta go
you know this whole ant business is
nonsense uh
we got a new ant queen in town boys
you've been promoted congratulations you
are uh the new hand queen
blah blah nice
nice
that's actually not bad because then
it's guaranteed to anyway and i can
actually afford them on a single turn
that's not bad
i like that
time to kick some ass what is this a
mole [ __ ] what is this a vulture
[ __ ] what do you think you're gonna
win [ __ ] oh infinite cat yes oh my
god wait
holy [ __ ] i can do so much
you are lacking sacrifice for that cat
oh right of course i forgot
of course
cat needs sacrifice
yes please thank you uh you're gonna
spawn
uh
oh [ __ ] my cat oh god oh wait i don't
have no attack what is that
it's fine
you give me a rabbit
keep me alive i'm uh no no promises no
promises
all right kill kill
put you right
here this is a good play
not a bad first hand if i do say so
myself and i do say so
myself
three
nice try bubbo
oh you are so gonna kill this thing but
at least i'm not gonna take damage so
screw you buddy i
win
oh
hey wait a minute
hey wait him
hey
i saw how that was supposed to go oh
what are you doing to me i can't do
anything with you stop staring at me
with those eyes where's my uyu rudy
you're gonna kill my cat knob i can't
no or i could give everyone flying for
this turn to win it anyway i'll do that
hey look at that all right see you guys
i win
pathetic my pelts are clean
oh you have the pill i thought i have a
free one
have a free one
all right i guess i'll take another one
not that i want another one in my
inventory
i guess i'll take another one not that i
want another one in my all right that's
enough for me
thank you for your patronage
i uh i now realized that the uh the
trapper wasn't or the you were the
trapper the traitor was what i what i
was looking for and yeah that didn't go
so good for me a group of star survivors
stood around and there's room for a
creature and the fire owns it warren's
role is his power
[Music]
all right
no way well maywe
may weigh yes is it like a 50 50 shot or
something is it like a not guaranteed
what happens why are you saying no way
come on
do it
the power of the still was enhanced by
the warmth
as one of the survivors began pulling a
knife from the pocket you were through
well i mean you say no way apparently
worked out just fine so shut up
i got a lot of wolf pelts or i got a lot
of pelts hey mole man what do we have
here mole
mole for the mole man more like all
right uh
well the clear and obvious choice is to
put you there get you out uh
rabbits now in my pocket
i can put this
down here
rabbit for
the ant
right
there not that it matters
i have another worker ant which i can
use to sacrifice on this cat
bada bing bada boom suddenly 4 damage
that's i got a good
i got a damn good deck
i got a i got a damn good
well
that's lovely i'll save that for a rainy
day
nice
okay that's dead
okay that's dead that's fine because i'm
gonna get my come on be sorry ah it's a
sacrificial stoke not the sacrificial
goat
all right you're gonna go there
yeah i know you don't like it but shut
up also i'm gonna win actually i'm gonna
win
hey i don't i'm not winning by overkill
a lot but that's okay
who needs it not me
all right raven elk and
lewis i don't like you loose you don't
look too good to me i'm gonna get the
raven just because i don't have anything
that can fly
and then i'm gonna sacrifice the raven
give something that i do like that
the flying urayuni the
unruly children will be captured by the
flying ooh
beware my words and listen well in the
night lies the flying oo yarudi with the
coming of the darkness and their waiting
of the dawn in those hours at the
darkest moments the flying ooyah will
come for your toes
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
it's what came over you the flank what
is that
what do i have there
mole man
a boulder a burke bun
a raven egg well this is all real nice
like butter you know how it'd be spider
what does this do
ah
what i'm gonna do for you there
or you there
get that for you there
boy you
there and then
well i guess i could just start chipping
away at that i get i guess yeah why not
i guess i could have done some damage
this turn but i didn't think about it
i don't think about a lot of things
hey stout man all right well i could do
with killing that ah you got no attack
you stinky [ __ ] you stinky [ __ ] right
i guess i'll just build on my hand
whatever
[Music]
nice try [ __ ]
um work grand huh yeah i'm good for now
[Music]
okay
it's a lot of things on the table this
porcupine is pretty much
solved so what i need to do okay if i
want to play the worker and i gotta kill
one put one there but that worker ant's
not gonna do enough against the raven
it's gonna die in the next turn
the mole man's
well the mole man's gonna do his tail
trick so that's nice that might work out
i don't know how that's gonna behave so
let's just see if i can get another cool
oh
okay well i got that in my hand now if
only i could get the flying uyuruli on
my side
let's see what happens with this tail
oh hey that did work out in my favor
though flying
ah
[ __ ] all right i've done nothing i
really wish i had a flying uyuruli i
don't even know if i can get rid of a
rabbit pill
um this is
fine
this spot you sure yes i'm sure shut up
and go away i have way too much resource
stuff
all right well this is not going well
for me
did i neglect dimension over kill damage
excess damage is not wasted
carries over the card behind the mingled
corpse of the victim lucky for you
well not lucky for me with these hits
ow
okay well that's a problem please be the
flying god damn it well i'm dead
god damn it god dude oh all these
resources cards it's not like these ants
are gonna do anything oh i guess i
should have played it last time because
if i would have played the last time
they would have put to i forgot that
health doesn't recover
ah frick oh
i'm dumb
i didn't even think about that god damn
that's totally correct oh there's no way
i'm done i'm dead i'm a dead man i've
got one bullfrog that can do flying
defense
i'm not even using it correctly i i
should have
oh i didn't even think about it i should
have done it better
well that was dumb of me to do that
but alas this is what it is i don't even
know it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine i didn't even put my defense
it doesn't even matter it doesn't matter
i'm
it's all gone downhill from here
[ __ ]
yep that's a lot of overkill on your
side
yep i deserve that
that was disappointing
i know i know it's disappointing i know
you i no one's more disappointed than me
you trust me
grimly
uh i'mma go gribbly because i need i
have so many like big point spenders and
yet i'm not spending big points
where's my big points
hey the eye thing a pitiful opossum
huh frozen opossum is created in your
hand a frozen possum is defined as zero
power five health frozen away
all right yeah why not
uh emergency squirrel i like the uh
emergency eye
i think that's better i think that's a
better go all right boss fight i only
needed one shot anyway so i'm either
gonna kick ass or i'm gonna ass kicked
me
and they are stood before you and then
you recognized immediately
it was
the trapper
he reached out to examine his wares but
he stopped you
sorry
but today you will supply the belts
shut up lucky draw
oh this is a lucky draw this is a lucky
draw
oh this is a lucky i don't like those i
don't like any of these
i don't like none of these love the
knives though all right let's get this
show on the road
yeah oh yeah you're gonna be killing
whatever the hell this is all about
back of the bull back on the board
oh yeah back on the board and just you
wait because there's more to this play
that you're about to see
you're gonna love this
watch this nonsense
sacrifice that to sacrifice that and
then unleash
my howling wolf
to kill that one i guess i could have
just
done something that's fine it's better
this way
your move big guy
stupid idiot
i don't like to look at the traps
ow well god damn it
or what do we got grizzly huh excellent
if only i had that goat back in my hand
i missed that goat got nothing to block
that damage but that's okay and last the
frozen opossum perfect it's the perfect
move i'm so secure
oh
wait a minute
wait hold on
that's not what i thought that the deal
was
wait a minute
hold on hold the phone
hold the phone put a wolf pedal down
there perfect
take that
i hope that doesn't destroy that guard
oh no
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god take my eye
yo
oh she's
that's fine it's fine it's fine yeah
take some of that
right
but god i did i do not think these
things through
partly because i don't really know
what's going on with them but whatever
didn't i play a warren oh i didn't play
a warren god damn it okay
oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay i need a squirrel to be able to
play
mole man
but i also want to be able to play the
warren
but that's no different than getting
just a card in my hand so i'm going to
play the mole man now because he can
take all of this damage it's fine
okay i got the start of something else
going on here not the adder
he moved ha ha take my tail
okay so i have the warren i want to play
this grizzly okay so if i play the
warren
i'm gonna need to get something for that
i'm willing to bet that i'm gonna pull a
great card here with resourcing
yeah
damn it
[ __ ] okay it's fine you're going to hit
the free tail i'm not going to take any
damage this turn anyway
yeah pick that
excellent oh the opossum is unfrozen
okay great okay so the thing about this
opossum this is gonna be the start of
every single game-winning move that i'm
ever gonna have because i'm gonna get
this grizzly out
because i'm gonna play
i'm not gonna get this grizzly out
because i don't need to get this grizzly
out i've already got a better plan i
know exactly how i'm gonna win this
how many health do i have i'm so good
okay i got it i got it i got it i got it
i got it i got it i got it okay this is
what i'm gonna do okay i'm gonna play
the stink warren here because then you
won't be able to do anything to me i
have a rabbit so i can play
something else next turn this is all
gonna stay there i'm gonna put the wolf
pelt down here wolf to wolf eat my ass
i've got a rabbit and then some things
that might work out in my favor
i guess i could have played the ants and
then i could have taken out the oh wait
no should i have done that oh shooty
duty
[Music]
oh
i want to get this grizzly out but i
can't and it's fine but i can't but it's
fine but it can't but it's fine but i
can if i put this here
and then i sacrifice both of these
no
that was dumb idea then i'd have to
sacrifice a war
but then i could kill both of you
it's worth it because the overkill's
gonna spill over it's worth it it's so
worth it
big moves this is how we do this is what
we're going to do we're going to get it
winning
bam carry over yes and then i'm free i
can survive that hit but i've got i've
got a grizzly that's going to wallop him
in his empty sack
he's never gonna feel again
what do i got
perfect this is exactly what i was
hoping for because he can never die and
he'll always give you more bones
wham
oh
and he can fall into the trap no problem
because it doesn't even matter
what an idiot
rabbit pill god damn it that's no good
if i sacrifice that doesn't add you know
what i'm not gonna risk it
oh no it's gone but is it what is it
though but is it though
i get a wolf pelt every time i activate
one of those traps
oh god damn
all right well you're not gonna last
long elka bears coming after you that
means i should probably
i should definitely
oh i need to draw a new one okay so what
do i have worker ant yeah let's keep
going my cards are interesting opossum
perfect so i put this here the opossum
can go opposite this dude
and then that that's fine
wham wham hit the trap get the cockroach
get a pelt
damn i love these belts it's pretty cool
and uh uh bada bing bada boom somehow i
turned this from game over to game me
and i love that about me i love that oh
boy good timing infinite cat thank you
for that big preach
let's go ahead and get these things out
i guess all right let's finish it
oh wait i forgot that's only one of the
hearts oh wait
wait i'm dumb
oh wow that
too fast
too soon
oh god oh no oh
what is that
what is that supposed to be
what do you mean
what is that
how would anybody
what do you mean too fast too soon did i
oh i'm beating the game too fast too
soon i see what you're doing here you
sack of [ __ ] you where's my flying oo
doolie if i had my flying uyuruli
i would win in this turn if i had a
flying ooyu ruli what do i have what do
i got over there what's over there is
there something else over there in the
darkness god if i had my fan flying up
in the air oh
i would win so good
i didn't know that i was gonna be going
up against this you [ __ ]
well fine all right too fast too soon
huh
if i had my flying ooh you rui
you would be so dead
you would be so dead you'll make you'll
make an exquisite pal i'd hate those
hands
hate the hands
that's [ __ ] and you know it mr
trapper man now you get shadow eyes over
here and you tell him that i'm pissed
off
my flying ooh you really never even
played i never drew it once stay there
no need to move
i'm afraid you're not dead yet hold
still
[Music]
where did i put that camera of mine
uh here it is buddy take that
and this one of these pathetic
do you really think i would leave film
in there
do you have any idea what that camera is
capable of
give me that
hey
we have a memento to create all right
i'm gonna make a good one this time
behold
your death card shall we begin to ink it
okay draw cost all right
i'm not gonna be dumb about this we're
gonna get a good one cost
cost of one blood from the warren i will
use
it's power and health ah this isn't
ideal for me but whatever power health
is good over here eh that's all right if
i had my flying ooh you ruley
now choose a card to extract the sigils
from i guess i could pull does it pull
both these sigils because that'd be good
let's see if does it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay that's a good cheap card there
there's mark emu
something remains i must capture your
visage i wish i had a better card to
like my flying you really
[Music]
hey
what's up pal not much for trading then
last one are you prepared to make the
right deals i was trying to woe a gift
from the angler if he was defeated
recently and wishes to redeem himself
it would be unfortunate if you were to
fall to the prospector before he was
given that chance
this hook is powerful
you may steal one of my cards with it
for that reason you will not find any
others along the path
use it wisely
all right whatever
what is wrong with your stink bug what's
wrong with the stoat seems a lovely
stink bug what's wrong with the stoke
what's wrong with these
[Music]
all right whatever i'm gonna find out in
the next episode because i'm all out of
time thank you everybody so much for
watching i'm really enjoying this game
anyway thank you and as always i will
see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you